What you can see now is that, although we have formally proven that our code
cannot violate this assertion, there still may be other issues,
which simply aren't properly specified yet.
So any proof can only be as good as the specification it relies on.
Which, of course, again is a call for good assertions.
Because if you do have good assertions, you get good specifications, and this
will not only help you a lot in debugging, you will also improve your testing,
and as we have seen, it may even enable the use of automated deduction tool.
But now, for a programming exercise.
It really, really annoys me that this function isn't entirely done yet.
Please go take this function and fix it such that this html markup is properly removed.
I promise this will be the last time we are going to be fixing this function.
Over to you.